Fox news media has announced it has
parted ways with the key Network host
Tucker Carlson that's with immediate
effect our U.S correspondent Mark Stone
has more on this for us and Mark well a
dramatic move uh by Fox he's one of
their highest or higher rating hosts I
think tell us more
yeah this is a surprise uh Tucker
Carlson if there is a a Fox News
household name in the UK then it is
probably him he is I I would say the
best known of the fox hosts outside of
the UK he is a celebrity uh here in the
United States without doubt his 8pm show
every night every weeknight on Fox News
has among the highest ratings of all Fox
news's programs he is provocative he is
a man who who upstairs anger as much as
he does Applause depending on where you
sit on the political landscape here in
the United States as of Friday he did
his show without any suggestion that
anything was going to to happen clearly
something happened over the weekends and
he over the weekend and he is out a a
brief statement from fox saying Fox news
media and Tucker Carlson have agreed to
part ways we thank him for his service
to the network as a host and prior to
that as a contributor he is a man who
has shifted right over the course of his
career at he was at CNN for many years
he worked for MSNBC uh for many years as
well but then moved to Fox News and has
been more and more provocative uh in
line with with Fox's output over the
course of the last few years now the
context probably is the Dominion case
that was settled out of court you'll
remember just last week this case that a
voting systems company had had against
Fox for lies that fox had made on air
lies that Tucker Carlson was allegedly
part of but by Mo by no means the only
host who who is it was caught up in all
this other household names here in the
United States like Sean Hannity like
Laura Ingram both of whom have shows
that follow Tucker Carlson's show on the
weeknights on Fox they too were caught
up in uh in what has been a very
difficult period for Fox I'll be
fascinated to see how Laura Ingram and
and Sean Hannity react to this news and
of course we don't have any Clarity on
whether he was pushed or whether he
decided to leave